everyone just wanted to say that these  killstreaks were captured in private  lobbies with BOTS because I suck but  that's not the point we wanted to show  off how every kill streak works out in  the battlefield so here's a compilation  of each and every one enjoy this is  watchtower passcode accepted beginning  launch sequence  [Music]  first of all radar ready for deployment  Jaguar 3-0 for personal radar coverage  [Applause]  [Music]  Jaguar 3-0 scramble encourage active  enemy counter UAV we've lost three  darling  [Applause]  strike a3 was dropping whiskey peed on  your bark  [Music]  we need an air support  okay  we need air support thank our two two on  station  [Music]  weapons engaged  request Rico flyover  [Music]